[Musik]
es geht um
Menschenleben es geht um Zeit wenn jede
Sekunde
zählt für die Patienten natürlich ein
riesen Zeitvorteil Traumaversorgung ist
auch
Zeitmanagement die Rettungsflieger vom
Christop Hanser
Lebensretter betraut schon ich liebe es
und vor allen Dingen als Rettungsflieger
darf ich ja quasi im Einsatz da landen
woo man sonst nie landen kann arbeiten
im
Grenzbereich und das ist eben auch das
was es ausmacht hier ist kein Tag wieder
anderen sie retten wenn sonst jede Hilfe
zu spät
ger doch es gibt Situationen da kommen
auch die Rettungsflieger an ihre Grenzen
so bei der Flutkatastrophe im Atal
2021 auch hier waren
Rettungshubschrauber im
Einsatz Menschen warten verzweifelt auf
iher Rettung doch die Hubschrauber
können nicht landen und von einer
wichtigen Ausrüstung gibt es viel zu
wenig
rettungswinden erst Stunden später sind
vereinzelt Winden im
Einsatz
ein Problem das auch die Stadt Hamburg
noch aus ihren Narben der Geschichte
kennt bei der Flut 1962 kamen 315
Menschen ums Leben viele erfroren weil
sie nicht gerettet werden
konnten lernen aus den Fehlern der
Vergangenheit frstoff
aus der in Hamburg stationierte
Rettungshubschrauber Christoph Hans ist
vorbereitet Notfallsanitäter assistentes
Piloten und Winden Operator ist er
trainiert täglich den Einsatz mit der
windeüber Köpfen dass der klimabandel da
ist und dass wir vermehrt mit
Naturkatastrophen zu tun
haben und der Stellenwert der Winde da
bin ich mir ziemlich sicher der steigt
nicht nur an unserem Standort sondern
auch woanders und er müsste im Notfall
mit der Winde aus schwindelerregenden
Höhen abgesalt werden Notarzt dr Markus
stuh vor dienstbeginnen wird der
Notfallkoffer
gecheckt wir wissen das ist alles
aufgefüllt die Verbrauchsmaterialien
sind vollständig so dass wir dann
beruhigt in den Einsatz starten können
und ohne ihn startet niemand Pilot
Markus Daniels fliegername Jack
Sicherheit hat hier höchste Priorität
Fehler wären
fatal Fehler passieren damit muss man
das muss man wissen wichtig ist dass das
Team versucht natürlich den Fehler nicht
durchgehen zu lassen sondern dass wenn
einen Fehler macht dass es dem anderen
auffällt und die Fehlerkette
unterbrochen wird der hubschraubber ist
jetzt
einsatzbereit wir sitzen hier und warten
in unserem Team alles ist vorbereitet
alles ist ready to go und dann geht der
Melder und dann kommt der Einsatz und
man weiß nie was ein erwartet der Melder
geht der erste Einsatz mehrere
Fahrradfahrer sind schwer gestürzt
mitten in einem kaum zugänglichen
Waldgebiet Landeanflug unter erschwerten
Bedingungen gucken wie viele verlze es
da
gibtche also mein Vorschlag hinten hin
weil hier weiß ich nicht wo ihr
durchkommen soll okay da vorne rechts
können wir da stehen auf der Weide das
sind
aber Kühe ne also die Einerstelle ist ja
unter uns hier ich hab nicht ich den RTW
der fährt der fährt jetzt rückwärts der
fährt zu dieser wir gehen na vorne auf
da zu Land da komen wir
oder guck mal links
dieese
Links da wo der eine im Garten steht und
dahinter ja okay also da komen wir auch
nicht wir müssen irgendwo einladen
können okay kleine Leitung
Telefonleitung undinter ist auch noch
ein Grad aber es sind gleich stauben
also mach gleich die Türen zu ich geh
hier
runter Ken die ein Acker muss kurzer
Hand als helipten da der Landeplatz noch
etwas vom Unfallort entfernt ist heißt
es umsteigen Notarzt Markus stur und
Notfallsanitäter örich die Feuerwehr
bringt die beiden zum Einsatzort ein
groß Aufgebot von Polizei und
Rettungskräften ist bereits vor
Ort die letzten Meter müssen die Retter
zu Fuß zu den verletzten Radfahrern
Intensivmedizin in freier Natur
Christoph Hanser und Pilot Daniels
warten auf ihrem Parkplatz im
Feld so parkplatzsuch ist ja manchmal
auch wie beim Einkaufen am Samstag um
jetzt wirklich ein schönen Platz zu
finden ja das war jetzt mal eine
sportliche Nummer ne wir wusen nicht
genau wo der Einsatz ist dann habe ich
die da er spä da unten im Wald etzt live
wir überlegen ob wir Winde fahren wir
haben vorbereit maßn schon eingeleitet
aber sagt sie Patienten hätten sie schon
im RDW und würden damit rauskommen und
daher war obsolet und da hinten war es
auch echt wä auch nicht gut gegangen und
dann haben wir da hinten gekreist und
sind dann natürlich Pferde willst du
auch nicht landen und zum einladen W es
auch m gewesen jetzt sind wir hierher
gekommen und hier ist ein schöner
Landeplatz ne und ja ich muss ja hier
für Buchführung muss ich ja den Ort
eingeben und jetzt im Moment weiß ich
überhaupt nicht genau wo bin ich
gelandet aber dann nimt man natürlich
hier die Hilfsmittel der Neuzeit Kalk
kalkkuhle ist das jetzt der Name den
nehme ich mal mit geh ins nächste
Programm rein und gucke was er mir denn
sagt
kalkkuhle er bietet mir nämlich schon
was
an
n noch andere rein das ist immer
spannend so lernt man die Gegend
kennen wilde Natur weite Wälder perfekt
für Biker für die Retter eine
Herausforderung die
Einsatzsituation war dass zwei
Mountainbiker hier diesen Weg entlang
gefahren sind und dann eine nicht
sichtbare Kante kam im Weg und der erste
Mountainbiker ist darüber gestürzt und
dann ist der zweite Mountainbiker auf
den ersten Mountainbiker dass sie sich
sozusagen verwickelt hatten wir hatten
beide Schmerzen in der Halswirbelsäule
bei dem einen mehr bei dem anderen
weniger wir nehmen jetzt den etwas
schwerer Betroffenen mit ist aber alles
gut dem geht's gut und der wird dann bei
uns in der Klinik einmal untersucht auf
die Frage ob er Verletzung an der
halswiürbelsäule hat die man versorgen
muss bei vermuteten Verletzungen der
Halswirbelsäule ist eine schonende
Bergung oberstes
Gebot 1 2 3 und vorwärts hier
aufpassen
auf einer Vakuummatratze wird der
Patient in den Rettungsflieger getragen
dadurch wird der Patient fixiert und die
gesamte Wirbelsäule stabilisiert zu
starke Erschütterungen könnten ansonsten
zu weiteren und schwereren Verletzungen
führen es geht zurück nach Hamburg in
die Berufsgenossenschaftliche
Unfallklinik Heimatbasis von Christoph
Hanser und hochspezialisiert für
Verletzungen an der Wirbelsäule der
Patient ist stabil und ansprechbar doch
das wirkliche Ausmaß der Verletzungen
wird sich später im Krankenhaus
zeigen der Patient kommt sofort in den
Schockraum ein Raum in dem
Schwerverletzte Notfallpatienten zuerst
untersucht und behandelt
werdenr
schön hier übernimmt ein Team aus
Fachärztinnen und Pflegern Radiologen
Chirurgen
Anästhesistin um gefährliche Brüche zu
entdecken muss der Patient gercht werden
Diagnostik in echt im
Nebenraum ein erstes gutes Zeichen dass
der Patient mit einem blauen Auge davon
gekommen ist und einigen schmerzhaften
Prellungen zurück auf der Wache der
Hubschrauber wird wieder aufgetankt der
Notfallkoffer aufgefüllt ein Einsatz mit
glücklichem Ende doch das ist leider
nicht die
Regel wenn alles ganz ruhig ist das ist
das ist schlimm also ich sag ihn eins
wenn man zum Einsatz kommt und
und es ein kindernotfall Kindernotfälle
ich habe selber vier Kinder
Kindernotfälle sind das die nehmen
glaube ich jeden in der Rettung mit
jeden also da kann man sich nicht von
frei machen von bei Erwachsenen ist das
so eine Nummer da denkt man sich ja das
ist halt Schicksal so ist das Leben aber
bei Kindern das nimmt ein mit und wenn
wir zum kindernotfall kommen und da
schreit noch ein Kind da sehe ich das
erstmal positiv weil wo es geschrienen
wird ist noch leben wenn man irgendwo
hinkommt und da hört man gar nichts das
geht am schon nahe und die Kind Notfälle
sind auch die die haften geblieben sind
da habe ich mehrere ja ich sag mal im
Rucksack den Rucksack kann man nicht
ablegen weil der ist einfach da kann
damit nur Leben und ja die sind dann da
gibt's halt nicht so schöne
Erlebnisse ein besonders tragisches
Unglück haben Notarzt und Pilot
gemeinsam durchleben
müssen der Einsatz der mir am meisten in
Erinnerung das ist ein Einsatz mit
zwei Kindern im Alter von so 5 6 Jahren
die Teilnehmer eines Gottesdienstes
waren gar nicht so weit weg von hier
einer großen Gemeinde 300 Menschen die
versammelt waren und offenssichtlich war
den Kindern langweilig denn sie haben
dann den Raum verlassen und die Umgebung
erkundet und sind dabei durch die Lücke
in einem Zaun von einem
Regenrückhaltebecken in das
Regenrückhaltebecken gerutscht al das
war das war wirklich ganz ganz übel in
so einem Rückhaltebecken für Wasser so
als quasi Reservoir für äh
Feuerlöschteich glaube Feuerlöschteich
halt so heißt so ein Ding es war am
Rande mit Plastik ausgelegt eine Leiter
die K man von außen sehen aber die
Kinder konnten nicht schwimmen die waren
weiß nicht vier F und dann ist der Ball
da reingefallen und dann war der halt
nicht ordentlich ordentlich gesichert
dieser Bereich da war eine große
kirchliche Veranstaltung und ja die sind
dann halt reingekrabbelt nach einer
Stunde oder so hat man die Kinder dann
vermisst und
ja dann sah man den balderbur noch
schwimmen und dann wurden wir halt
alarmiert und letztendlich haben die
Taucher die Kinder geborgen und ich war
der erste Notarzt der an dieser
Einsatzstelle ankam und dann die
Versorgung dieser Kinder organisieren
musste
und im Ergebnis sind beide Kinder
verstorben aber das ist natürlich eine
Situation die einem erstm im Gedächtnis
bleibt gerade wenn man eigene Kinder hat
m in der Aufarbeitung ist aber klar
diesen Kindern war letztlich nicht mehr
zu helfen weil das Ereignis also der
ertrinkungsunfall und der Tod durch
Sauerstoffmangel schon soweit so lange
zurücklag dass wir
sie einfach nicht haben retten können
kein Mensch der Welt hätte sie retten
können weil das Ereignis einfach fatal
war sowas nim natürlich
[Musik]
mit der nächste Einsatz ein
Verkehrsunfall auf der A20 in melenburg
vorp auch das gehört mit zum
Einsatzgebiet von Christop Hanser rund
20 Minuten
Anflug vorbei an
schwer
man weiß einfach nicht was
kommt ich gehe be sowas immer davon aus
wie Land und übernehmen ein versorg
Patienten zum Transport
trentrum kann natürlich auch eine
Wundertüte sein als erthelfer wäre für
Christoph Hanser schon viel
lebenswichtige Zeit verloren gegangen
bei einem so langen Anflug müssen die
Unfallopfer bereits versorgt
sein Rettungswagen und Notärzte sind zum
Glück schon vor
Ort
Landung mitten auf der gesperrten
Autobahn zwei Autos sind mit hoher
Geschwindigkeit zusammengestoßen für die
Rettungsflieger geht es jetzt darum die
Patienten zu stabilisieren und
schnellstmöglich in ein Traumazentrum
für Schwerstverletzte zu bringen die
Wurt des Aufpralls lässt sich bei den
zerstörten Fahrzeugen erahnen viel
knautschston ist nicht mehr übrig
[Musik]
geblieben
paent stabil ist mittelschwer verletzt
wir bringen Sie nach Rostock an die
Uniklinik die Uniklinik Rostock 60 km
entfernt an Rettungswagen würde dafür
über 40 Minuten brauchen die
Rettungsflieger
[Applaus]
unterzählen lebenswichtige Minuten auch
ist der Flug wesentlich schonender für
die verletzte als die Fahrt auf der
Straße
die Patientin ist stabil und muss nicht
beatmet
werden die Zusammenarbeit zwischen den
Rettungsfliegern und den zuerst
eingetroffenen Rettungskräften hat
optimal
geklappt es war jetzt vort so wie wir
uns immer erhofft kommen an
undorgt
Schmerzbehandlung Stunde nicht gestanden
perfek
gelaufen nur noch einaden
[Musik]
und Irritationen dann kurz vor der
Landung ein Landeplatz auf der Klinik
ist in Sicht doch dort wartet keiner auf
die
[Musik]
R der neue Heliport an der Uniklinik
Rostock ist noch nicht in Betrieb
erwartet wird chr Hans beim alten
Landeplatz
muss die Patienten die letzten Meter zur
Klinik
fahren Übelkeit ist eine bekannte
Nebenwirkung des rettungsfluges dour
begleitet sie zu weiteren Untersuchungen
in die Klinik Rostock wird nicht oft von
den Hamburger Rettungsfliegern
angeflogen Pilot Daniels analysiert den
ungewöhnlichen Landeanflug interessant
war der Anflug unser Navi hat uns zum
dachlandeplatzt der war mir neu wusste
dass sie ein bauen wusste allerdings
nicht ob der schon aktiv ist oder nicht
da wir Gott se dank die Info hatten dass
RDW vor Boden gebunden ist habe ich ja
noch mal ein kleinen Schlenker gemacht
weil sonst stehst du da oben nämlich
erstmal und bist erstmal ja W der
Patientin da hoffnungslos im falschen
Laden egal wo die Rettungsflieger landen
Fans finden Sie
[Musik]
überall es geht zurück nach Hamburg rund
40 Minuten Flugzeit Zeit auch mal den
Flug zu
genießen zurück auf der Wache Jörn örich
bildet eine Kollegin in der
windenrettung aus sein Berufsbild nennt
sich Hems
letztendlich ist es so dass der Hems
mehrere Aufgaben hat er ist Assistent
des Piloten also er ersetzt den
Copiloten sitzt also im Hubschrauber
vorne links und unterstützt den Piloten
in fliegerischen Aufgaben eine
Einsatzstelle schaltet er dann um zur
Medizin und unterstützt den Notarzt bei
der medizinischen Versorgung versorgt
eigenständig Patienten wenn mehrere an
der Einsatzstelle vorhanden sind also
ist ein Hems im Grunde nonstop das ist
nonstop im Einsatz örich muss als
windenretter schwindelfrei sein und
tritt fest denn im Falle eines Einsatzes
muss er von vorne links seinem Platz als
assistentes Piloten nach hinten rechts
wechseln da wo die Winde ist außen über
die Kufen all das mit im Einsatz in
Schwindel er reggender Höhe rechts Rand
fliegen zum Platztausch
ausgeschlossen Zeit fährt
weiter die Herausforderung für den
Piloten ist es den Hubschrauber ruhig
und genau über der Einsatzstelle zu
halten diese Abläufe müssen sitzen daher
gehört die Übung zum Alltag der
Rettungsflieger geh auf diee zu ja wir
sind
so ja wie hoch bist du jetzt wie hoch
140 14 das unter die Kufe ja so und Seil
fährt 140 Fuß das sind rund 40 m die der
Docker am stellernen fen hängt bis er
wieder Boden unter den Füßen
SPT im Zusammenhang mit der
Flutkatastrophe im
Al
ist erkennbar geworden dass es
Indikationen für die windenrettung durch
Hubschrauber gibt die vielleicht nicht
zu sehr die Medizin im Fokus haben
sondern überhaupt die Möglichkeit
Menschen aus anderweitig nicht
erreichbarem Terrain zu holen von
Dächern im Rahmen von überfluteten
Häusern und ähnliches und hier in der
Stadt sehen wir den Vorteil vor allen
Dingen darin dass wir die Möglichkeit
haben den Notarzt die Notärztin an Orten
abzusetzen im Rahmen des normalen
Einsatzgeschehens an denen wir
eigentlich gar nicht landen können
Landeplatz für die Rettungsflieger in
stäten eine
Herausforderung gerade im urbanen Umfeld
haben wir das Problem dass man dann
natürlich nicht über landen kann kann
man sich vorstellen wenn überall
Bebauung ist dann kann man da sehr
schlecht runtergehen und auf die Straßen
immer absperren sind auch nicht immer
Polizeikräfte so schnell Vorort dass
alles abgesperrt werden kann dann muss
man sich entweder im Umfeld veruchen
oder wir haben wir jetzt neuerdings die
Winde letzten Oktober mit dem mit der
Winde kann man natürlich den Arzt Ziel
genau zuführen dass der auf je
schnell beim Patienten ist und wir
gucken dann wie es weitergeht die
windenrettung erfordert höchste
Konzentration die Retter müssen Punkt
genau am Einsatzort abgesigt werden die
Piloten brauchen eine ruhige Hand und
fremde Augen die fliegeris Besonderheit
beim findeneinsatz ist Genauigkeit als
erstes die
Vorbereitung man muss vorbereitet
reingehen man darf sich da nicht hetzen
lassen das ist wichtig weil wo Hektik
entsteht entstehen die wollen wir hier
nicht muss so vorstellen wir wollen über
den Punkt W Hubschrauber jetzt hier ist
dann sehe ich ja nicht den wo ich ein wo
ich den Arzt hinbringen möchte das sehe
ich ja gar nicht mehr weil ich d mit dem
Hubschrauber drüber steh also ist der
der Hems dafür verantwortlich dass wir
über den Punkt auch kommen und dann
meine Augen
quasi der Flugplatz am
berufsgenossenschaftlichen Klinikum in
Hamburg steht Rettungsfliegern zur
Verfügung die Patienten in die
hochspezialisierte Klinik bringen gerade
berufsunfallopfer finden hier die
bestmögliche Behandlung für Christop
Hanser geht es zum nächsten
Einsatz ein Mann ist in seiner Wohnung
mitten in Altona zusammengebrochen es
geht um Leben und Tod er muss
wiederbelebt werden hier zählt jede
Sekunde der Einsatz mit der Winde wird
vorbereitet
[Musik]
R
bereit jetzt macht sich das tägliche
Training an der Winde bezahlt gleich
kommt der Winden Operator außen über die
Kufen zum Notarzt hoch über der
Hans
bereit machen zum Tür öffnen so geh
[Musik]
auf alle
Dr ist das ne
ja da RTW wo ist RTW da ist RTW da zum
pederwagen würde ich
[Musik]
sagen Ken nicht
soef
dieen genau stell dich mal ein hin oder
wir nehmen die wir nehmen das hierw
kommt der Wind kannst du dich in die
alle Stellen dies alle abfegen und dann
nach 2 Uhr abkien wenn wir in die
Richtung kommen würde das gehen dass wir
so nach 1 Uhr ungefähr abfliegen ja na 1
Uhr ja pas
okay0,55 okay er geht auf die Kufe wie
ist der
powercheck
Single ja wie
viel bevor der arztus fast 40 m Höhe
abgesilt wird werden noch alle
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen gecheckt
Verkehr
komm
stationär
abprochen
jaicherung so ich lass den schon mal
unter die Kufe ja D kannst du noch mal
langsam voraus vierus
vius d
[Musik]
jetzt Laterne müssen wir auch noch
vorbei noch mal voraus 2 voraus 1 voraus
Stopp Position Hal
rich steuert mit Kommandos den Piloten
denn nur er sieht wo der Arzt ankommen
mus so noch mal vorsichtig rechts
ein Position ist gut noch mal vorsichtig
rechts
ein und Position halten Position ist gut
se fährt 26
m Position halten conf
areaa im Boden am Boden bei 37 m
Position halten ausgehakt sal fährt ein
SE
steigen der Notarzt ist beim Patienten
und die Crew hat jetzt Zeit einen
geeigneten Landeplatz zu suchen auf
einem Parkplatz an der Elbe landet der
Hubschrauber auch hier unterstützt örich
den Piloten sass kein Hindernis
übersehen wird ich glaub so ist gut ja
alles klar wenn das bei dir passt passt
es auf jeden Fall run
[Musik]
ja not bereit an Einsatzstelle könntest
du mich am
altenter abholen hier sind wir zur
zwischenung gegangen
das alles sind wertvolle Minuten die
dank der Winde nicht verloren gegangen
sind jn örich wartet auf seinen Shuttle
zum
Einsatzort mit der Polizei geht es
weiter zum
Patienten trotz Blaulicht und
Sonderrechten gerade bei einer
Reanimation kann das schon die eine
Minute zu lang sein die der Patient
nicht versorgt
wird
doch in diesem Fall ist Notarzt stuh
bereits vor Ort und versucht den Mann
wieder zu belben während örich noch
unterwegs
ist dramatische Szenen am
Einsatzort
wie geht's Patienten ja der Patient ist
leider verstoren wir kam zu
spät und konnen den Patienten nicht mehr
helfen bzw er hat einfach schon zu lange
ohne Lebenszeichen in der Wohnung
gelegen der Nachbar hat man versucht ihn
wieder zueleben aber das war leider
erfolglos und ist mit frühen 58 Jahren
verstorben der Tod ist der traurige
Begleiter der Rettungsflieger ihn zu
akzeptieren fällt schwer gerade wenn es
um noch junges Leben geht in einem
Nachbarlandkreis von Hamburg ist im
Speckgürtel von Hamburg zu einem
Verkehrsunfall gerufen wurden wo eben
ein Schulkind
überfahren wurde das Kind hatte seine
Schultüte noch dabei und ja das ist
natürlich dann schon schwierig wir
wollten eigentlich unter reimationen
dann ins Krankenhaus fliegen und ich
habe dann wir sind dann mit dem
Rettungswagen wie man das so macht zum
Hubschrauber Gefahren
ähm unter Reanimation wir haben alle
Dinge die wir an der Einsatzstelle an
reversiblen Ursachen bekämpfen können
wir haben die Atemweg gesichert wir
haben so viel Sauerstoff zugeführt wie
wir nur konnten und damit sind wir dann
an unsere Grenzen gestoßen ähm und
konnten eben NS mehr machen und dann
habe ich gesagt
also lass uns alle noch mal einmal
gucken wie viel wie viel Blut haben wir
jetzt hier im Rettungswagen wie
viel wie wie vi viel Blut passt in
dieses Kind und hat dieses Kind jetzt
noch eine Chance zu überleben und das
Kind hatte keine Chance zu
überleben ja das ist schon ziemlich
tragisch manchmal sind selbst die
Rettungsflieger nicht schnell genug doch
es gibt wohl kaum Beruf bei dem der Tod
und das Leben so dicht beieinander
liegen und die positiven Erfahrungen
einem die Kraft geben die negativen zu
[Musik]
ertragen besonders schöne Einsätze sind
in der Regel die wo wir zügig an der
Einsatzstelle sind und ohne große
Zeitverzögerung direkt transportieren
können und einfach diesen Zeitvorteil
des Hubschraubers voll aus spielen
können und wenn wir dann am Ende auch
noch erfahren dass der Patient wieder
genesen ist erfolgreich operiert und
rehabilitiert wurde
ähm dann ist es immer besonders
erfolgreiches Gefühl und ich denke genau
dafür machen wir das
[Musik]
auch